hi everyone
my name is daniela masachetti and i'm a
machine learning researcher at microsoft
research in cambridge
and today i will be talking about how we
can use fuchsia learning to realize
teachable ai systems
we are moving into a technological era
that is setting up the world just for me
i can adapt my work tools to benefit and
reflect me
i can become a virtual avatar that looks
just like me in a meeting
i can get entertainment suggestions that
are perfect for just me and soon even my
healthcare might be personalized to me
and my exact genetic makeup
but is me
really me
as we start to look critically at the ai
technologies that underpin these
personalized experiences
we realize that how ai systems represent
me
is actually only a coarse-grained
version of me
for example the coarse-grained category
of gamer
may no longer fit for a new dad who now
wants simply games that allow him to
divide his attention more easily
or the coarse-grained avatar for man may
be insufficient for a veteran who no
longer has his right forearm
let's take me as another example
an ai system may place me in the
coarse-grained bucket of women
we define this bucket by a whole set of
features that we typically associate
with a woman
that she likes beauty and fitness that
she's good with people
that she likes high heels and buying
clothes
that she wants to have children and many
more
but if we dig a little deeper we may
find that these coarse-grained buckets
do not capture all the facets of our
identity
some features may be missing from the
buckets so for example that i'm south
african and growing up in south africa
has a much stronger influence on my
identity than say my gender as a woman
or that i work in tech and i've been
coding from a very young age which
perhaps doesn't commonly appear in the
bucket of women
also some features in the bucket may be
irrelevant
for example that i don't care much for
high heels anymore after spending the
last 18 months shuffling around at home
in my slippers
or that i don't like buying clothes i
prefer to design and make them myself
just like me
millions of people may find that they do
not fit into one of the coarse-grained
buckets that underpin many of our ai
technologies today
yet we have wholeheartedly adopted this
bucket-based approach in ai
perhaps because it aligns with how we as
people also tend to group other people
into buckets to help structure our view
of the world
however by doing so we may be creating
ai systems that far from serve many
people's individual needs or
appropriately capture their identities
let's take lynne dewey for example
lindiwe was born in south africa and she
works as a data labeler for a local
annotation company
the company has just signed up for a
virtual meeting tool so that they can
connect their kenyan and south african
offices more easily
the functionality is overall great
however lindiwe is running into a few
problems
she likes to turn the background effects
on whenever she's in a meeting she knows
that there's nothing more unprofessional
than having one of her boys running into
the room or one of her colleagues eating
lunch in the background when she's in a
client meeting
however the background effects don't
always work for lindiwe
she likes her hair in an afro but the
segmentation doesn't capture it well
she also likes to wear a traditional
head scarf and earrings on some days but
it doesn't work well for the for those
either
instead
every morning lindiwe has to strip back
some parts of her identity so that the
technology will work for her
if only there was a way that it could be
personalized to her so that she could
express her full identity
more freely
now as responsible ai practitioners
every time we come up against such an
example that seems unjust
we try to rearrange the buckets we add
more buckets we take buckets away
and we reshape the buckets
we may feel satisfied for a while
until the next example of failure comes
off the queue and we must begin again
for example in lindyway's case we might
decide to break the bucket of women into
women with a dark skin tone
and women with a light skin tone
but actually a woman with a dark skin
tone who comes from america versus south
africa
may be quite different so perhaps we
also need to split by location
but after we've done this we may find
that a south african woman with a dark
skin tone shares many features with
other groups of women in south africa
so perhaps we need to add another split
or merge these buckets somehow
and so we can go on and on
what we each need instead
is a bucket of me
in which each of us can choose the
facets that represent ourselves
now one of the most human attributes is
a desire to shape our own identity
a bucket of me is something a person
creates for themselves it is not learned
automatically by a machine from simply
observing a person or their interactions
instead a person must have the agency to
capture their own unique needs and the
freedom to choose how they want to
identify themselves to the world
the vision of teachable ai is to give
each person the opportunity to tune an
ai system on their own bucket of me
it is a young field that draws on
interactive machine learning and machine
teaching
and it enables an end user to tune an ai
system to their personal needs and
identities through examples and other
high-level constraints that they provide
the result is an ai model that is
personalized to the end user
to imagine an example of this let's go
back to lindiwe
first she would capture a few images of
herself
and label her silhouette outlines
showing all the aspects of her that are
important
her own bucket of me
she would then pour her bucket of knee
into the teachable system
it will learn her silhouette on the fly
and finally will deliver a model that is
personalized to her
one that will be able to segment her
correctly and not cut off her headscarf
or her earrings
crucially lindiwe is in control of the
data she puts in her bucket
so if next week she decides to change
her hairstyle
she could update the examples in her
bucket and re-personalize her system
but is this vision of teachable ai just
that an idealized vision or can we
actually realize these systems
the biggest challenge we face in
teachable ai is that
the model must personalize to a new user
by learning from only the data that is
in that user's bucket of me
a bucket containing only a handful of
examples
this contrasts the dominant machine
learning paradigm
where systems are trained on buckets
containing thousands of examples in each
however machine learning is on the cusp
of overcoming this challenge
recent few shot learning algorithms
allow a model to learn completely new
concepts from just a few examples
say between five and ten
these algorithms have made great leaps
and strides in recent years and opened
the possibility of completely
personalized teachable ai experiences in
the future
in the next few slides i will explain
how these few shot learning algorithms
work in the context of lindiwe's
background effects
if you'd like to dive into more
technical details then the two
references i've provided here are a good
starting point
the first presents an early vision of
how we might build models that have this
ability to learn new concepts
dynamically in deployment
while the second is one particular few
shot learning algorithm called mammal
which really kicked off the more recent
research in this field
right so now on to a very high level
description of how these few shot
learning algorithms work
at their core they have two phases
a training phase
and a teaching phase
we've already covered the teaching phase
here a user in the real world like
lindiwe
would give the system a small bucket of
examples and the system would use that
data to then deliver a model that is
personalized to that user
but for us to deploy a system that is
teachable in this way
a machine learning practitioner has to
explicitly train the system beforehand
to know how to handle just a small
bucket of data per user
to do this the practitioner would create
hundreds thousands of buckets of me
each one belonging to a different user
and containing say a few labeled
examples of that user
during the training phase
we'd pick one user at random
and we'd feed in a few of those examples
into the model so that it has a chance
to learn how to segment that user
immediately afterwards we'd feed in a
final example as a test and then reward
the model if it properly segmented that
user
and we do this repeatedly for many
randomly sampled users in our training
set
the result is a final model that is
dynamic
once deployed it could learn to segment
any completely new user by looking at
just a few training examples in their
bucket of me
we can contrast this with standard
machine learning algorithms which don't
group the data by user
nor do they pass it to the model in
these mini user sets
instead training is done by simply
randomly sampling images from very
coarse-grained buckets
each containing hundreds to thousands of
examples
in contrast the result here is a static
model that has simply wrote learned this
fixed set of buckets
so i've presented this grand vision of
teachable ai and a class of machine
learning algorithms that we could
potentially leverage to achieve it
but how do we get started
as we've seen there is a broad range of
applications that could be made
teachable toward completely personalized
ai experiences
our team project tokyo is exploring
teachable systems in the context of
assistive tools for people who are blind
or low vision we believe that giving a
blind user the flexibility to
personalize their tools will really
drive the next generation of innovation
for a community with a diverse set of
needs
building on this we are excited to
announce a new teachable ai benchmark
that is grounded in teachable object
recognition for people who are blind or
low vision
similar to lindiwe and her personalized
background effects
a teachable object recognizer will allow
a user to add just a few examples of a
personal object to their bucket of me
the recognizer will learn this object
from just those few examples
and deliver a personalized recognizer
that can then identify that specific
object in any number of new real world
scenarios and the user could do this for
any number of personal objects they have
we couple this benchmark with the orbit
data set
a new data set collected by people who
are blind or low vision
the data set is a collection of short
video clips of objects
captured by blind people on their mobile
phones
importantly the data set is grouped into
one bucket per user where each bucket
contains the objects belonging to a
single user along with their anonymized
videos
now our initial work on this teachable
object recognition benchmark has
highlighted the broad set of
multi-disciplinary challenges that lie
ahead of realizing fully teachable
systems
and so i'd like to wind down this talk
with a discussion on some of these
opportunities
first a sampling of challenges in the
machine learning space
a teachable system needs to personalize
consistently across users
few shot learning algorithms have made
great progress so far
but they haven't really been explored
within this user-centric framework
our initial experiments show that the
performance of state-of-the-art few shot
learning algorithms
are highly variable across users
for one user the recognizer personalizes
really well while for another really
poorly in some cases to as low as 25
accuracy
the second area of focus is that a
teachable system needs to be robust to
noisy data
a user's bucket could contain mislabeled
examples or examples that are just
difficult to learn
our results show that these
state-of-the-art algorithms can identify
new objects with only 60 accuracy in
these real-world cluttered environments
as i've shown here on the slide
these points highlight the need for us
to move away from clean curated datasets
and toward more real-world data
and to also think about new ways in
which these models can handle data and
label noise
this could range from being able to
identify and filter out poor examples
from a user's bucket
to understanding how these few shot
learning models quantify uncertainty in
the face of these different types of
noise
a second set of opportunities lie in the
hci space
first a teachable system needs to be
explainable
as the user adds data to their bucket
and personalizes their system the system
should be able to communicate what it
knows and what it doesn't know in a way
that is easy for the user to understand
and then act on
so for example it might need to notify
the user which items in their bucket may
be hampering the model from
personalizing effectively
now identifying which examples are
difficult is a non-trivial machine
learning problem but deep thinking will
also be required to know what
performance information to draw out of
the model to then communicate to the
user
a second area of hci focus is that a
teachable system also needs to evolve
with the user over time
as they go a user will add and subtract
data from their bucket
and will repeatedly personalize their
system
this is a shift from the typical
paradigm where models are usually
analyzed at a single slice in time
and so we need to extend our
understanding to how a user and a model
works symbiotically over an extended
period
finally teachable systems open several
research engineering opportunities
first a teachable system needs to learn
quickly for example in a matter of
minutes seconds to minutes each time a
user edits the data in their bucket
it also needs to do this in a
computationally lightweight manner
both of these challenges are relevant
because
learning from the data in a user's
bucket may need to happen on the user's
device for example their mobile phone or
their computer perhaps for privacy or
other reasons
in our current work we are explicitly
looking at a class a few shot learning
algorithm that can personalize to a
single user by passing their data just
once through a deep neural network
this is computationally super
lightweight and would allow learning to
happen on a resource constrained device
like a mobile phone
so i'm sure you'll agree that this
teachable ai vision really presents a
wide range of both pure and applied
research challenges all of which offer
an incredibly exciting space for those
across the machine learning and hci
disciplines
achieving this vision will not only
allow us to realize teachable object
recognizers for people who are blind or
low vision
but also has the potential to
revolutionize a wide range of other
applications
from personalizable holo lenses on
factory floors and in hospitals
to personalizable background effects in
teams
and so with that i'd like to close with
three key take-homes
the first is that teachable ai is a
paradigm shift in machine learning which
will move systems from coarse grained
buckets
to highly individualized buckets of me
one for each end user
second few sharp learning is on the cusp
of making these teachable systems a
tangible reality
we need to continue driving research in
this phase to make models reliably
teachable
and then finally we offer a call to
action
we present a new teachable ai benchmark
and dataset and hope that you will join
us in exploring the multifaceted and
multi-disciplinary field of teachable ai
thank you to all the amazing people
behind this work
and finally thank you for listening